[Music]
it's time today we're unboxing the brand
new iPhone 11 and not just one iPhone 11
we have all three models here we have
the iPhone 11 in the purple and we have
the iPhone 11 Pro and the iPhone 11 Pro
max in the new midnight green let's
unbox
let's start with the iPhone 11 in purple
I keep calling it lavender lilac but the
technical color right here says iPhone
this purple is so awesome like this
reminds me of Easter candy I also loved
the new mint color but seeing these in
person at the Apple event just all
together it was like a beautiful Easter
basket the main difference obviously
between the 11 and the pro is the
cameras so this only has two and also
the display is different the iPhone 11
has the LCD where's the iPhone Crowe has
the super Retina Pro super edible it's a
better screen than the 11 let's see what
else we have in the box obviously we've
got our paperwork I was really hoping
for lavender apple logos it's okay I'm
not upset I'm not upset but think about
it for next time so we have the smaller
charging brick that's another difference
between the 11 and the pro the 11 comes
with the smaller charger whereas the pro
comes with the faster charger which is
USB C and a USB C 2 lightning cable
we've got some Lightning earbuds and a
lightning connector first iPhone down
so this is a new midnight green color
and seeing this at the Apple event and
you were watching on the screen it looks
like a more muted type washed out color
but this color looks different in every
single light that I've seen it in so far
and now it is in my lights in my studio
so let's open them up
[Music]
finally hard not overreact because a lot
of you guys in the comments you always
think that I'm overreacting but I am
genuinely extremely excited about this
especially because it is a new color
because I didn't think that it was gonna
be something that I'm into and now
seeing it here seeing it at the event it
is a really cool color it's kind of
green but it's also kind of like a teal
but then it's also a little bluish like
I have no idea what color this is the
pros now come in four different colors
so you have your midnight green you have
the space gray the gold and the silver
and I think that I'm gonna be getting
the silver because I ordered the white
ceramic watch one of the things that I
think is really awesome
is this is all one piece of glass this
part is the frosted and this little
raised part isn't a separate and it's
raised way less than it looked like in
the rumors and all the leaked images
that we saw the introduction of these
three cameras is pretty awesome and the
camera is what makes these new phones so
special you have a telephoto an ultra
wide and a wide-angle lens and the
front-facing camera also has some
updates as well you can now shoot in 4k
and not only 4k but you can also shoot
in slo-mo I know who they pulling the
new phrase slow fees I'm not sure if I'm
the fan of the word slow fees but you
better believe that I'm even ashtag it
and takes low fees all the time so I'm
the part of the problem this is a
previous version as you can see they
also move the Apple logo down and this
phone without a case is so incredibly
slippery and you can tell with this that
because it has that matte finish less
slippery it's also stronger glass it
never gave us anything specific as to
like what that means but the glass is
stronger and if anyone is going to do
durability tests and not on purpose it's
always accidental another thing that at
school is the clear cases that they have
you can actually see the colors and I'm
usually not a fan of clear cases but if
you really want to see what the phones
look like this is what you got to do
this actually feels pretty substantial
because some of the clear cases that
you'll get like on Amazon and stuff are
very thin and flimsy this is pretty it's
pretty nice let's put you in before back
wrong phone this is really iPhone 11 one
thing that I almost was surprised by is
the fact that they didn't call this the
iPhone 11 are they dropped that so now
this is just the iPhone 11 you guys it
is iPhone season oh if you guys haven't
subscribed to my channel already please
do so yes I'm crazy I am a little over
at the top but this is something that
I'm just so excited about and I know
it's crazy but ever since I was little
I've been such a huge fan of Apple
especially if you're new here you might
not know that be able to get these
things here in hand and show them to you
is just it is a dream come true let's
see what else is in the box I mentioned
this faster charger so as you can see
this is USB C and they have the USB C to
lightning cable so now that everything's
unboxed let's take this stuff outside I
will be doing way more in-depth reviews
and looks these cameras and phones in
the next week or so
hit the belt to be alerted when I go
through videos but now let's take our
new little babies outside good even the
blue the purple and green move it
together we are down in my usual spot in
Santa Monica about to get some sunset
shots here on the new iPhone now we're
going to do some video and a little
photo test for you guys just to kind of
get a first little look because this is
the first time that I'm actually getting
to spend some time with it one of the
new camera features that I really love
is when you click right here this little
arrow button that'll give you a wider
angle view so you can click that to go
back and it'll automatically give you
that view when you rotate the phone now
hey guys it's Tyler I gave it a shot
Slovo selfies are also a thing on the
iPhone 11 if not just the max so let's
get a slew fee I can't I can't even say
it
[Music]
I knew I watched prepare for a reason
today I was gonna make a Pantene joke
but that's what I use this is a Pantene
commercial all right now let's test this
out on the iPhone 11 Pro max oh my
goodness there it is
looks just about the same obviously one
of the new highlights is the three
cameras on the pro version so let's test
it out take a nice landscape photo over
here let's start with the wide-angle
view zoom in to the 1x
and now to the 2x oh the cool houses
over there
I still love how cool this is because
when you're in this view you can see
what the other lenses are seeing
[Music]
front-facing 4k video this is gonna be a
good pest because the lighting is a
little bit harsh right here so here we
go hitting record now alright it's a
little bit deeper here in Santa Monica
getting sweet I died I think I have food
on me oh I probably do
like
[Music]
on the red sky with my
stewey portrait selfie on the 11 as well
[Music]
so take a few photos with the iPhone 11
and honestly you guys are deciding which
home to get this phone is really great
so don't think just because this isn't a
pro that it's not an awesome phone
what's great about this is you will get
the ultra wide-angle but you also have
the 1x regular zoom you won't have the
telephoto on this one but you do have
some digital zooms so if you do need to
zoom in you can but for the most part I
think the addition of this wide angle is
so a highlight of all the iPhone 11
models is the portrait mode so before it
would really only work on people but now
because these cameras are more
stereoscopic this allows the cameras and
the iPhone to get a better sense of
depth so it'll be able to pinpoint
exactly what should be in focus and what
should not up close and personal to the
sign and Tyler
and it's doing a really great job
[Music]
so fortunately before you always work
with people but now you can use it on
objects and even pets so my friend ed
has two super cute cats and weekend Gus
so I'm basically bombarded him right now
[Music]
so this is what he looks like
off and on do you change the culture
yeah yeah look at that look at that cat
oh wow look at this wider angle we can
Gus in Lincoln Gus in weekend Gus wow
this looks great
[Music]
ya know an image stabilization is
already pretty steady so I wanted to try
it out though to add a little bit extra
stabilization using the Osmo mobile 3 so
let's let's do a little walk here
[Music]
look what a great job this does
adjusting the contrast and highlights to
make everything look
I love it oh that's me
[Music]
[Applause]
we gotta get this I gotta get this shot
so what if we use the other phone to
prop up this phone this is a really bad
idea
why did I bring a tripod silly me
terrified but live your life I spend too
much time trying to get the time-lapse
and now the Sun is gone but this is
really good because now we can test out
night mode go to the apples were first
split in two by a tripod and then we'll
test it out you can also do it handheld
but the iPhone can sense when it's on a
tripod so that allow you to get a longer
exposure shot so we'll do some hand held
by a tripod and we'll be set
chopping 3% cashback EPPICard let's
unbox this real quick
[Music]
this is I think one of the first really
good examples that we have and look at
the detail that this all pulled out and
the coloring this looks awesome connect
mode is gonna be so fun
[Music]
we're basically back where we just
started for sunset and now that it's
super dark I've got to be so cool to try
to use the tripod mode and in track lock
mode it automatically can detect the
phone isn't moving six seconds so it's
cool because it has the little countdown
right here so you can see how long
until it's done whoa that's really crazy
I'm pretty impressed I wanted to try
some light painting so basically that's
where you paint with light and because
the exposure is open you'll be able to
see the light traveling let's see what
this looks like whoa my goodness it's so
cool so these are not really cool I
would love to try this out in a much
darker situation because they're
definitely still is a lot of light
pollution out here but this was so much
fun if you guys so much for watching I
hope you guys enjoyed this first look
unboxing and a camera test of the new
iPhones there will be many more iPhone
videos to come so stay tuned make sure
you subscribe hit the bell and all of
the things that we tell you to do
comment like whatever if you don't do it
it's okay I'll just be sad alright
little phone let's go home
[Music]
you